o Olá eu sou a doutora Carla Laís estou
aqui para falar sobre sono porque o solo
é importante para nossa saúde física e
mental bom meu trabalho com sono há oito
anos desde que eu vim fazer meu
doutorado aqui nos Estados Unidos e mais
ou menos nessa época comecei a utilizar
as minhas redes sociais para falar da
importância do sono e qual o impacto na
saúde física e mental bom e os agentes
sociais que eu não falei para falar
sobre sono e eu postei esse Twitch gente
vamos parar de Romantizar insônia seu
cérebro precisa dormir para limpar todas
as tranqueiras neurológicas restará a
função imune e performance física quer
chegar aos 70 anos tem demência vai
dormir bom eu postei esse tweet e fui
dormir para minha surpresa no dia
seguinte quando eu
a imagem 60 mil internações constituídos
e para mais surpresa ainda não só as
interações mas também as respostas por
exemplo meu sonho consegui dormir
direito sofro com insônia uns 18 anos
meu nunca fui fã de dormir mas a
pandemia acabou comigo e por último eu
fico sem dormir já acordo com dores no
corpo nariz entupido ansiedade confusa
então é
e já mostrando para gente que a pandemia
dentre tantas coisas ruins não deu
oportunidade de pensar nos nossos
indicadores de saúde e o sono é um
indicador de saúde muito menosprezado
mas durante a pandemia nós passamos a
prestar mais atenção nisso né além
desses comentários eu recebi também
muitas perguntas do que é um sono ideal
para o adulto e jovem o sono ideal é
entre 7 e 9 horas de sono por noite mas
o melhor sono de qualidade não é só ter
determinadas horas de sono também é
preciso passar pelos ciclos do Sono
desde o ciclo mais leve até o ciclo mais
profundo então nos ciclos leves por
exemplo do Sono nós temos alteração da
frequência cardiorrespiratória alteração
da temperatura corporal e também reparo
físico nos ciclos de sono mais profundo
e nós temos é a consolidação da memória
a remoção dessas tranqueiras
neurológicas que são as placas de
beta-amilóide que se não forem removidas
elas vão se acumular no cérebro e tem
uma alta correlação com a incidência de
doença de alzheimer e demência então é
importante o passar pelas determinadas
fases do Sono dos ciclos do sono e
também ter o número de horas adequadas
né nós sabemos que o sono é importante
mas quando o sono não vem a saúde parece
mas como é que o nosso corpo sabe quando
é hora de dormir e quando é hora de tá
acordado bom nós temos um relógio
biológico no cérebro e esse relógio
biológico se comunica com o meio externo
através da retina então a presença de
luz no meio ambiente no ambiente ao
nosso redor como
e esse relógio biológico que é dia então
esse relógio bloqueia a produção de
melatonina E com isso nós ficamos
acordados e todas as nossas funções
metabólicas relacionadas à estar
acordado são desempenhados na mesma
forma também na ausência de luz esse
relógio biológico identifica ausência de
luz estimula a produção de melatonina E
com isso nós dormimos e as funções
metabólicas relacionadas a dormir são e
a ativadas nelas acontecem então no
espelho do sonho mas quando o sono não
vem a saúde parece e nós temos vários
estudos que mostram a correlação entre
saúde física e mental e privação do sono
mas aqui devido a banda de Mia e também
a devida o espaço de tempo que nós temos
eu vou me focar em três é o primeiro é
resposta imunológica Então não é
coincidência
é que quando a gente não dorme bem a
gente sente mais cansada a gente ferver
Pado com mais facilidade é é nós sabemos
que a privação do sono reduzem até a
setenta por cento de células natural
Killers que são células importantes para
a função metabólica Além disso há uma
exacerbação da resposta inflamatória
durante a privação do sono e também o
crescimento tumoral fica aumentado a
privação do sono então não dormi bem
aumenta os riscos de ficar mais doente
ou ficar doente com mais facilidade mas
também temos uma relação grande entre
sono e saúde mental cerca de setenta por
cento das pessoas que têm depressão tem
insônia olhando para a população
saudável nos identificamos que cerca de
35 por cento das pessoas com insônia tem
ansiedade isso antes da academia agora
durante e após a pandemia esse número
aumentou para 65 por cento então nós
sabemos que
é a mais uma vez mostrando que a saúde
mental está relacionada com sono e por
último a questão da memória e do
aprendizado como eu falei eu brinquei
com sobre as tranqueiras neurológicas
que precisam ser removidas do cérebro
durante o sono também importante falar
que durante o sono acontece a
consolidação da memória né o tempo que
nosso hipocampo tem para visitar todas
as coisas que a gente aprenda Orante dia
identificar o que pode ser armazenado e
em que vai ser descartado como se fossem
várias caixinhas que nosso cérebro
organismo durante o período do sono
então você que tá ouvindo não dorme bem
já tá preocupado se vai ter um depressão
umas transtornos de ansiedade ou seja
tem uma resposta a diferenciada acaso
tem a infecção por convide-os a longo
prazo vai ter neném e se algum problema
de memória calmo a ciência consegue
o biológico existem diversas formas de
fazer isso mas nós trabalhamos com uma
medicina do solo centrada no paciente e
nós tentamos fazer intervenções sem o
uso de medicamento então nós conseguimos
utilizar intervenções que podem ser
feitas na sua casa né não precisa estar
no centro de pesquisa para fazer essas
intervenções mas sem intervenções
efetivas para melhorar a sua qualidade
do sono e também para melhorar o
funcionamento dos seus ciclos
circadianos o seu relógio biológico
essas intervenções combinadas nós temos
por exemplo após terapia EA atividade
física mas não é só fazer o uso essas
terapias o importante é utilizá-las no
momento ideal para o seu relógio
biológico Quando é o seu tempo adequado
de fazer essas intervenções nós
conseguimos avaliar conseguimos
certificar e identificar o melhor
momento para fazer Essas atividades
e vai para aquele paciente de acordo com
o relógio biológico da quinta e paciente
então Através disso. Conseguir melhorar
a qualidade do Sono melhorar a resposta
imunológica e reduzir ansiedade
depressão e garantir um envelhecimento
saudável e uma vida saudável hoje além
disso nós recomendamos rotina acordar e
dormir sempre no mesmo horário mesmo
durante a quarentena mesmo é trabalhando
de casa é importante acordar e dormindo
no mesmo horário para comunicar com o
relógio biológico que aquele horário de
dormir e aquele horário de acordar e
finalmente importante nós para nós
trabalhamos em casa com o computador
estamos no celular também muito tempo é
importante lembrar que é pelo menos uma
hora antes de dormir evitar a exposição
de telas é a gente sabe que a exposição
à luz bloqueia a produção de melatonina
então
ou menos uma hora de dormir e 20 todas
as telas para dar oportunidade para o
seu corpo fazer a produção natural de
melatonina e ajudar a dormir melhor e
ele faz os problemas que a gente já
falou lá no começo de resposta
imunológica de programas de memória
problema de saúde mental é claro que não
dá simplesmente para dizer que todo
mundo tem que dormir 8 horas por dia não
dá por exemplo para prescrever 8 horas
de sono por noite para uma um paciente
que chega para o centro de pesquisa ou
que chega pedindo uma variação do Sono
nós sabemos que a nossa sociedade
funciona 24 horas por dia sete dias por
semana então o trabalho noturno é
importante E além disso a gente sabe de
questões de justiça social por exemplo
que algumas pessoas vão ter que acordar
quatro horas da manhã pegar duas
conduções para chegar ao trabalho então
não dá sim para dizer que tem que dormir
8 horas por noite por isso é tão
importante cuidado centrado
hoje a gente consegue fazer avaliação e
adaptação para cada pessoa para ver o
que é o prioridade para aquela pessoa e
conduzir o cuidado de acordo com o que a
realidade de cada um então não se
cuidado centrado no paciente para
adaptar o conhecimento científico para
cada pessoa e favorecer a qualidade de
vida individual dizem que dormir é para
os fracos mas eu como sempre essa do
Sono digo que dormir é o que nos faz
fortes e dormindo também a gente sonha
eu mesma há muitos anos sonhei em ser
cientista lá na minha cidade assim é
pequena de Miracema sem recursos sem
dinheiro sem referências sem saber como
chegaria até aqui eu tive aquele sonho
mas tive também a minha família que me
apoiou que me ensinou a lutar pelos meus
objetivos a vencer os preconceitos E com
isso eu consegui
e para realização dos meus sonhos eu
espero que essa fala sobre sono inspire
os seus sonhos também durma bem
E aí